who here's a bayesian
who wants to be a bayesian
yeah everyone wants to be one all right
so with that almost no introductions
everyone please welcome andrew gellman
uh thank you nice to meet you all um
i
i think today um
i'll give you i'll
i'll tell you some stories that
and i'm hoping that you'll be able to
um
you'll be able to make use of them in
your own work so i'll try to figure out
how to make that connection um because
as the the story uh well there's a
saying that theoretical statistics is
the theory of applied statistics and
what we do is the most important thing
in understanding what we do
which means we need to reflect upon what
we do so when i'm speaking i want you to
think about your own work and how
these ideas are relevant or or perhaps
not
so let me
okay i'm going to start with a story
from a couple years ago which was
estimating the um
number of people that had coronavirus
and
i was a study was done by some stanford
professors of the
um where they they gave people
covet tests i don't remember the details
it was the kind of cova test that's
supposed to say whether you have the
antibodies so it's supposed to say
whether you had ever had it and they
surveyed three thousand people in the
county in california that contained
stanford university
and out of those one and a half percent
had coveted so you can kind of estimate
that the covert rate is about one and a
half percent um which was
kind of well you can you can estimate
that that won't be quite right for a
couple reasons so the first thing is
that the test has have some false
positives and false negatives
when when
something is a very low
rate a low prevalence in the population
then the false positive rate can be very
important so you need to adjust for that
the other problem was that the survey
over represented people who lived near
they asked people where they lived and
they were all residents of the county
but it over represented people who lived
near stamford and underestimated people
who lived further away
so
they did some survey adjustment for that
the people who lived further away had a
higher covert rate
and so when you do this adjustment you
get a higher number so when they did
both adjustments they got an estimate of
about three percent instead one and a
half percent three percent was really
big it was higher than people thought so
the study got a lot of headlines
uh
some colleagues and i looked into this
and it turned out
that we
well it turned out that it helped to use
a bayesian approach as jared would say i
guess
and we
we in particular we needed to account
for uncertainty and the false positive
rate and that that was driving a lot of
like when you account for the
uncertainty in the false positive rate
you end up with an
interval for the
rate of people who had ever had covert
that went pretty much all the way down
to zero now i don't think that zero
people had it
but i think that there is a lot of
uncertainty even a sample of 3 000
people isn't really enough if you're
trying to estimate something that has a
prevalence of one percent when the false
positive rate is in the order of one
percent
so we reported that there was more
uncertainty
which was fine um
going forward we wanted people wanted to
use this method for other problems so i
was working with so
i was working with some colleagues in
australia
who were doing pretty much using the
exact same model but this time they were
trying to do a better job of post
stratifying and adjusting for
differences between the sample and the
population
so they started with a prevalence and i
i believe it was similar it was around
well let's just say after adjusting for
the false positive rate the estimated
covert rate was around one percent
and then
they
um the data the sample size was larger
there was enough data that they could be
pretty sure it was it was positive
um
as we increase as we post stratified and
more variables so you can post stratify
on on age and sex and personal
characteristics and also geographic
characteristics where people live
as they increased as they post
stratified more and more um
their estimates
uh the the estimated covid rate kept
i don't remember which way it goes but
it doesn't really matter for this story
okay so i'll say it kept it kept going
up and so it kept going up like it was
like one percent and one and a half
percent like not huge like any of these
numbers were kind of plausible but it
was drifting upward now
that's not like a surprise in the sense
that or maybe it was going down but
again it doesn't really matter so it's
it's not
problematic that when you do more
adjustment the estimate changes more
like that's the whole point of doing
adjustment is that it might change
but
it was kind of weird because
we then did the multi-level regression
post-stratification analysis
post-stratifying not on the population
numbers but on the sample numbers so you
can do that you can do mrp to a survey
like to itself and post stratify in
itself it still gives you more stable
estimates and
more stable small area estimates
but it also gives you a population
estimate if it were causal inference i
would say it's the sample average
treatment effect instead of the
population average treatment effect but
in sampling it's just the sample
estimate versus population estimate
anyway we went back and as we went
forward adjusting
for more and more things the sample
estimate kept drifting too and it just
didn't seem right like it's again not
that it's impossible but we looked more
so we looked and we saw that as the s as
we were adjusting for more our estimated
false positive rate was going down and
when the false positive rate goes down
it attributes more to real cases
and i think there was something weird um
we're still kind of in the middle of
this because these are very busy people
but i think that the next step was to
simulate fake data from a world in which
the model was true and see if this would
happen when we simulated fake data from
the world in which the model is true
this didn't happen we didn't have this
problem
but we're having it in our problem
um then we thought maybe we should
simulate from the prior and when you
simulate from the prior it's kind of we
use kind of weak priors when you
simulate from the prior you get really
weird results because
it like a lot depends on how low the
false positive rate is so that makes me
think maybe it's a problem with our
prior
i kind of want to stop here um and just
say like as a story that's kind of
something that happened okay that's
that's one story now i'll tell you
another story now
i was
working with a student of mine who was
[Music]
who had a physics background and so i
was talking with him because there was
an example that i would always give
when teaching um and i would i gave it
was kind of a a fake history of least
squares was a way to help students
understand least squares based on
understanding math so i told the
students how you know how two points
determine a line right three points
determine the plane so it's also true
that five points determine an ellipse so
if you have five points i think this is
right
that an ellipse has five parameters so
if you have five points from an ellipse
you can draw the ellipse that goes
through it so then i said imagine your
gauss or laplace back in the in the dawn
of quantitative science and they're
plotting
um planet the motion of planets if you
have
a planet has an elliptical orbit
approximately if you have five
measurements of this the planet you can
draw a curve through it and that's the
ellipse what if you have six mo what if
you have six measurements what do you do
like you could pick the first five the
second five you could pick various sets
of five what if you were like 30 points
and you wanted to draw an ellipse
through them you could pick
you could pick the i guess i have to do
it here so you can see it you could pick
these five or these five or these five
so you could imagine a statistical
method where you pick all the sets of
five and draw all the curves and then
you kind of average them well like so
that kind of gets you to least squares
right
in fact
actual linear least squares it's not
well known fact that with regular old
linear regression with one predictor you
can actually get the least squares
regression line by taking all pairs of
points and connecting them with lines
and averaging all those slopes but it's
a weighted average where you weight the
slope by the square of the x difference
between the two points
well that kind of makes sense like if
you think about because what if you have
two points with the same x then the
slope's infinity but it gets weighted by
zero squared so that gets knocked out so
it doesn't matter anyway that's a it's a
kind of fun
formula of a fun intuition
but then you can continue and say
what happens if what if you have a
planet and it's going like this
and then like a death star comes in from
hyperspace and then the planet it starts
going like that like it's okay what
happens if you try to fit like well you
could fit an ellipse to these points or
these points or you could fit to these
so that it would be hard to get from one
one to the other there would be hard to
get a solution that's an illustration of
of the folk theorem of the folk theorem
of computational statistics which is
that when you have a problem with your
computation you often have a problem
with your model
so in this case there's a kind of two
stories and and neither one
neither one fits all the data so in some
sense you don't want the the solution
okay
with those as our starting points uh i
want to talk now about
um
metaphors of statistics or data science
i think we can't say statistics anymore
so i always say statistics or data
science
that's fine like words change i don't i
don't mind that at all like it's like
that's the way it goes you know that's
that's completely reasonable so i have
two metaphors for statistics or data
science i i think they're both valuable
metaphors and we use them in different
ways one of them is statistical
practices engineering and the other is
statistical practices science
so statistical practices engineering
it's like you think of like building a
bridge or maybe like you're you're
building your you're designing a product
right so you think about how it's going
to be used and you want it to be you
want it to work in a bunch of settings
like how do we build a bridge i'll never
build a bridge but like how would i
build a software product i would start
with a simple example a little model i'd
test it
then i get it out there once it's out
there i'd have beta testers and so forth
and i'd have a some sort of continuous
quality improvement
going on well that's that's kind of how
it works with
our statistical methods right like we
have
um we have ideas they work on certain
problems then we try them out we put
them in articles and books and we have
people like continuing to do it
continue to do these things
and it's it's a it's an engineering
process you're continually trying to
improve it and also continually trying
to figure out what went wrong with it
the other metaphor is statistical
practices science
and i i like to so
you could say that statistical practices
engineering is when you're developing a
method statistical practices science
arises when you have like one data set
or one problem coming up
so an example would be that um oh i
didn't finish sorry
okay hold those thoughts
okay i didn't finish the planetary
motion so i had this example and when i
would teach class i would always do it
on the board i'd write it in the board
and then i thought well let me
illustrate it like like in stan like why
not actually do it and see what happens
if you put the death star in and try to
fit the model and see how it doesn't
work
so i i started with a simple example you
have a sun and a planet this planet's
moving around the sun and you have 30
measurements of the planet it goes like
from here like it was we i did like a
little more than half of an orbit
and
you you throw newton's equations into
stand and have it figure out the
position of the star and the position
and the position of the planet at each
time the mass of the planet you know all
the all the parameters
and so
i simulated data and i asked the student
to do it because he he knew physics so i
figured oh because stan has differential
equations so i don't want to put in that
it's an ellipse right that's kind of
cheating i want to actually put in the
differential equations of motion and
then have it just do it that's more
pretty right so he did that and he found
something funny he ran eight chains and
like five of them did really well and
found the parameters just fine but three
of them were really bad
and
actually it's one of these funny things
where if you've simulated four chains
you could just get lucky and have all
four be in the right place
but otherwise like you have problems and
if you look at the parameters when it
was wrong they were really really wrong
it was they were
they were terrible um
we that happened sometimes in
computation that the the um the
objective function is very flat when
you're far away it's kind of hard hard
to find things
um so i i said well in real life you'd
have a little bit of prior information
on these parameters so let's try it with
a stronger prior and it was still having
this problem over and over again so we
had to look at it very carefully
and it's we're simulating from the truth
right they said let's strip down the
model so we're going to say that the
star we know the position of the star we
know the initial position of the planet
like we we said so we only had like two
parameters left or maybe even one left
it was i think then it worked but then
we added a couple parameters and was
still having this problem
and it was it was doing this and then
it turned out
it was kind of funny if you looked at
the at the the likelihood function it
was like
there was like a maximum likelihood
solution and a range near it they were
all very reasonable for one of the
parameters let's say it was like the
mass of the planet and then you go out
the likelihood goes down and then it
very slightly goes up
and then goes down and very slightly
goes up now when i say very slightly
goes up i mean the value of the
likelihood function was like 10 to the
minus 10 000
times the i mean that's not one half one
ten thousandth is high one ten to the
ten thousand as high but no no prior
will get rid of that really uh because
it really went down and then up if you
looked at the the the inference the
estimated parameter like you want the
planet to do this and what it was doing
was going around like one and a half
times
which was a real and if you if you have
like a one and a half times like the the
planet is is is very heavy it gets
sucked into the star
um
then
you
like it's a terrible fit but it's a
local maximum and it's a terrible local
maximum but it the things near it are
even worse you should really never be
there so you can actually solve this in
different ways if you have eight chains
and some of them don't work then you can
you have to throw away the bad ones
which is fine like you can
compute these you can estimate the mass
of these
parts of the density and say it's so low
that you don't need them
or you can do predict you could do leave
one out predictive model averaging which
is called stacking and get rid of it or
you can just use good starting points um
i so i learned something very important
from this example
was that you either have to be using
good starting points or you have to be
willing to throw away these chains which
all of us make sense there's no there's
no statistical reason why you can't pick
your starting values for an algorithm
there's no statistical reason you can't
throw away chains that are far away from
where you want to be
but we had been in a kind of
rut in which we were always like using
default starting values because like
you're writing computer programs you
don't want to have to specify your
starting value but sometimes you do
right so we kind of learned something
so
i guess
okay so that's the end of that story now
let me get back to what i was saying
about the analogy so statistical
practice engineering statistical
practice is science um so i would say
like
when we're doing statistics uh there are
three tasks of statistics there's
estimation
exploration and adjudication by which i
mean sometimes we're estimating
parameters in a model sometimes we're
fitting a model in order to explore data
and sometimes we're trying to adjudicate
between different models now the in the
covet example i gave you it was pretty
much straight up estimation problem
but if you notice what i was doing when
i talk to you about these examples this
is what i want to get at okay is that i
was
acting like a scientist in the sense
that i was standing outside my model and
data and trying to figure out what was
going on
and i feel like this is an aspect of
statistics that's not in the books
and not not even like in my own books
like
and
so let me ask you this i want to
reflect a moment on what is science okay
so i wan when i say science here i mean
like
not like a null hypothesis you know like
hypothesizing like my null hypothesis
not a statistical model i mean start i
want you to start with a hypothesis like
salt helps beans grow faster
that is i want you to put yourself in
fourth grade okay you are now in fourth
grade you're this high and you are
learning about science and what they
tell you
is about science you start by forming a
hypothesis like salt mix beans helps
beans grow faster then you gather you
run you run in you design an experiment
i'm gonna have these two these two pots
of of beans and i am going to put the
same amount of water in both i'm going
to put more salt in this then more then
i'm going to get i'm going to
run the experiment i'm going to gather
data
then i'm going to evaluate my hypothesis
and modify my hypothesis design new
experiments like what if i find nothing
do i say the hypothesis was false does
it mean that i need more data
do i want to try different conditions
maybe it depends on the temperature so
forth
that's kind of what we do
and i gave you a couple examples from my
own work i can give you more i'll just
like i'm gonna like throw examples at
you for for a moment okay i was
contacted by someone from wikipedia
because they were doing some a b tests
and they did a test where they were
testing some silly little thing they
said this is a silly little thing and
they they said
rhetorically why are we testing silly
little things because it's free to test
silly little things people are on
wikipedia anyway they have the the
screen that goes up saying would you
like to pay three dollars to help
wikipedia do good stuff
and like once it's there they can put
the screen and they can do it in
different colors they can do different
things they're doing it anyway they
might as well experiment so experiment
all sorts of silly things and they tried
a silly thing they found a very large
effect an implausibly large effect why
was that what's going on was it they're
doing multiple comparisons they've just
looked at too many things and they
finally found this did they do the
statistical model wrong is there a bug
in their code like
well it turned out
it turned out that that they weren't
actually like
something it was either it was a bug
somewhere because
um they they had they ran the experiment
for 12 hours and they had the data for
how many people each hour got the
treatment and the control and for a
couple hours it was equal and then
almost after that almost everyone was
getting the treatment and nobody was
getting the control and it happened that
the baseline level of country the
experiment was from 4am to 4pm 4pm to
4am and in the middle of the night
people go on wikipedia but they when
they get that screen they're less likely
to give money for for whatever reason or
those people are less likely to give
money right that the night owls
so because the treatment was assigned
more likely to be signed at night it
looked like the treatment negative
effect but if you would adjust it for
the time or just did the damn
randomization correctly or not lost half
your data or whatever you would got a
reasonable result okay that's a story
another story
is
ethnicity okay well i'll tell you a
bunch of years ago some psychologists
did this experiment where they told they
gave people a bunch of a quiz they give
you each quiz gives you four cities and
they'll say which is closer is new york
closer to boston or san francisco closer
to la
is denver closer to salt lake city or
minneapolis closer to
detroit etc lots of pairs of cities
those are kind of tough ones but they
gave them some gave people some easy
ones too lots of pairs of cities each
time you have to answer the question you
answer enough of these then you can use
a statistical model to estimate your
mental map of where the cities are well
they they did it on a bunch of people
and then you get this mental map where
of course like cities in the west are
kind of close to each other and then
cities in the east are like really far
apart because people like have that
mental map i guess if you give the map
if you give the question to people who
live in california it might look
different than if you give it to people
who live in new york so forth they did a
similar thing where they asked well they
did a bunch of different things they
also asked the same thing with animals
so you could say like which animals
people think are more similar to other
animals
very interesting line of reasoning
i decided to do this with
ethnicities and nationality you ask
people questions like which is like
irish and italians are they closer than
germans and french people right well
like iris ireland is far from italy and
germany is from close to france yet you
know irish and italians in america
there's some similarities somehow
culturally you know whatever so you have
this whole story you can so you can get
you we we did this we didn't do it we're
designing it um to and the idea would be
to get people's mental maps of
nationalities and religions and cultures
and then you could ask questions like do
liberals have a different mental map
than than conservatives
it's just a different project
something completely unrelated
a bunch of years ago we published a
paper called enhancing democracy through
legislative redistricting
very clever right like gerrymandering is
supposed to be bad right no it's good
for democracy we're enhancing democracy
through late how could it be well every
10 years they redraw the district lines
and there was a concern first that
there would be partisan bias that
parties would redraw the districts to
help them and hurt the other party
second that there'd be a lack of
electoral responsiveness because they
would draw the district lines to protect
incumbents so that was considered bad we
did an analysis based on state
legislatures from the 1970s and 1980s
this was a long time ago that we
published this and we found that
actually after redistricting there
tended to be less partisan bias and more
electoral responsiveness more
competitive districts than before
redistricting which seems odd right well
the reason is that redistricters are
under a lot of constraints
so they are constrained to
keep equal populations in the districts
also they were constrained in the
sensitive that most states or many
states had divided government and so
they had to compromise to pass a
redistricting bill and finally the
courts would throw out the most
egregious gerrymanders as the saying
goes so we we um
connecting this to
what is science and all so we have a
bunch of hypotheses like that we you
come in with some models of the world
like how redistricters work it's a
mixture of what i call adjudication
between different hypotheses and
estimation that we're trying to estimate
the effects
we fit a model estimating the effect of
redistricting and then we found that
there is an interaction
and i won't go into all the details
except to say the interaction was very
important
we did we had a lot of data issues
things happening in individual states
that we had to kind of handle
um
[Music]
i feel really bad about this project
it actually it won an award like we won
an award for it from the american
political science association we were
like this was influential work and
that's why i feel bad because actually i
don't think
legislative redistricting enhances
democracy now i haven't studied it
formally but it looks like there are
some states like wisconsin
where there's it's really
anti-democratic and conditions have
changed
and we should have written a paper
saying back in the 1970s and 1980s
redistricting enhanced democracy but we
don't know what happens in the future
so our paper had a big implicit model
and the big implicit model was what
happened in the past is going to be
descriptive of what happened in the
future but we usually care about the
future and that's fine right like i
can't
knock our paper for not being a crystal
ball
but i can knock us for not at least
speculating like not saying if we wanted
to say
we consider that the effects in the past
will continue in the future because the
effects in the past arose because of
certain conditions such as competitive
states of blah blah blah and we consider
we expect that these conditions will
continue that's fine but we didn't say
that right we just just just just and i
feel really bad
so
but what i really want to get out with
those examples was how what they were
what we were doing was like fourth grade
science like the wikipedia thing right
like what's happening there's a there's
like this weird phenomenon let's try to
understand why why are we not so we they
started with a certain hypothesis but
then once you get the data you have this
so there's like two levels of science
right so the first level of science is
why you're doing your study in the first
place like i have a hypothesis about
nationality and ethnicity that's why i
want to do this study about right the
nationalities and the ethnicities the
mental map i have some hypotheses
they're kind of vague um a little bit
more vague than salt makes plants grow
beans grow faster but not that vague
like i mean salt makes beans grow faster
as a vague hypothesis too right because
it's got to depend on the conditions but
then when i start thinking about
gathering data and we simulate some fake
we simulated some fake data and we found
it was actually harder to recover the
positions of these groups than we
thought it would be then we're doing
this other kind of science like this
kind of detective work thing where we
start gathering data at that level okay
so when i say gather data i kind of mean
two things one thing i mean is like
gathering data like what we inherit have
theories of redistricting so we gather
the data about competitive elections but
then the second thing is when we're in
the middle of doing our statistics then
we start doing these like we have these
little hypotheses like wait the model
doesn't fit why not
is it a bug in my code
is it
that actually my prior is too weak and i
didn't really think about that because
in the past i had analyzed data with
where i didn't need a strong prior um
is it
is it there like is is there a problem
with the data that i hadn't seen like
and let me probe it let me do some
experiments let me do some leave one out
cross validation let me try things
what i would like you to do just for a
minute okay or two minutes is to talk
with your neighbor
about a project that one of you has
worked on and i just want you to frame
it as a fourth grade science project and
and like consider like what you were
doing in your data analysis or whatever
where you were like being a little
scientist so could you do that for me
for a minute please
so here you can talk with that gentleman
there
hey
you can talk with
so
[Music]
okay
so
so this is kind of important in fact
like often like at the end of my talk i
like to say like what do you what can
you take home from this talk that's what
you can take home from this talk is
is to reflect on on what you're doing
and think of it now this is so
what the so this is not like
it's not in our books that that we do
this right so what is this not well it's
not a pre-registered study
um it's not that you fit like think of
paradigms for statistics so one is the
pre-registered study and you you have
the statistical properties of your
method another paradigm of statistics is
the kind of bda paradigm that you're
going to fit a big model
and you might have to work at it and
build up but eventually you have this
big model and it's just sitting there
right
but that's not what you're doing either
exactly and oh another another paradigm
which is from econometrics is that
you're doing inference for something
called theta and that's like what you
care about
now
it's not that but yet i'm not saying
that you should forget all of what
you've learned about statistics so
here's a bunch of key issues and
statistics that they come up okay data
quality and measurement
bias
variance
partial pooling
extrapolation generalization
causal identification
and mathematical modeling now these are
all important issues like they come up
for example in our enhancing democracy
through legislative redistricting
project obviously there are issues of
data quality how do you even define a
competitive district and measurement you
have issues like uncompet
uncontested elections um other things
that you have to deal with
we have to think about about
mathematical modeling like even things
like using normal distributions like are
they appropriate bivariate models time
series models we care about causal
identification so to what extent can we
think about redistricting as a treatment
and so forth so we think about all these
things but i feel like when i'm doing
stuff
um
[Music]
i'm doing like
when i'm doing i i i'm actually like
doing a lot of
experimentation um
like
and so like here's a kind of thing i
think these are the things that put in
the abstract but like what if you have
we have some of our hypotheses are not
scientific hypotheses so it's not a
hypothesis that
redistricting is good for democracy or
salt makes beans grow better whatever
it's a hypothesis in internal hypothesis
like n equals 200 will be enough for
this study right or a simple
two-dimensional distance model that will
work i don't need to go beyond two
dimensions
i'm fitting a model i'm doing a b
testing and i think the if treatment
effect will vary over time i think a
simple random walk model will work with
a normal prior on the jumps
um
or like i have a research question yes i
think it's a i can estimate it from the
data so these are hypotheses that are
hypotheses about data quality hypotheses
about bias hypotheses about
extrapolation i think for my hypothesis
that i can just do inference for this
popul this sample and not worry about
non-representativeness
in order to
study a hypothesis like this i'll do a
little experiment like i might do
typically these experiments are
simulation studies but sometimes you
might actually go and gather a little
bit of data or analyze existing data you
could do mathematical modeling which is
a kind of shortcut to simulation
the simplest example is a sample size
calculation so i
example i've talked about before was
from nearly 20 years ago now it was a
study somebody did of beauty and sex
ratio and they found that
beautiful
parents were more likely to have girls
and it was based on a survey of of 3 000
people
and it was statistically significant and
it got some press
uh this this result um we can do a
little bit of i have a hypothe there's a
implicit hypothesis in their study not a
hypothesis about biology by hypothesis
about statistics and that's the
hypothesis that 3 000 people is enough
people to estimate a
difference between
[Music]
sex ratios of pretty and ugly parents
well we can do a little bit of
statistics actually this one i don't
even need to do a simulation i have n
people and
uh half of them are beautiful and half
of them are ugly that's not quite right
but let's we're simplifying life um
n over two of them have babies and over
two of these people have babies i want
to know the estimate the difference in
the probability of a girl birth so i get
a difference and a standard error the
standard error is the square root of 0.5
squared over n over 2 plus 0.5 squared
over n over 2 which is
1 over square root of n
so for example if n
a
were
thousand
then one over square root of n is .01
one percent so you can as with if you
have a ten thousand people in your study
uh that should allow you to estimate the
difference in sex ratio a difference of
one percentage point
um but actually if you look at the
literature you never see differences
a difference comparing beautiful people
to ugly people that would be much less
than one percentage point um like you
can look at difference in sex ratios
comparing old mothers to young mothers
black parents to white parents rich to
poor all sorts of things and you get
differences that are half a percentage
point or less you would not get one
percentage point so
we can kind of do this
another example is measuring error model
so we often have problems we're
regressing y on x but x is measured with
error we can learn a lot by simulating
some fake data
and or we could actually just fit a
measurement error model and stand but
either way like we can evaluate the
hypothesis that we usually use which is
that we don't care about measurement
error or omitted variable bias it's a
common thing that people will do they'll
say what if there were some
variable in there that we have to deal
with
um
so
again like i
i feel that um
that there's a mismatch between
what we do and what's in the textbooks
and and because i don't quite have an
answer that's why i'm giving you this
kind of
disjointed talk um
and but but let me just say that like
our theories are there for a reason but
like our theories are themselves only
rough models of what we do and so one
example is adjudication and null
hypothesis significance testing so
adjudication is a real thing and it's my
term for i have two models of the world
and i want to choose one
like
not i'm not talking about decision
making i'm not saying like i wanted a
judy i want to decide whether to do the
innovation or not whether to take the
drug or not you know whatever whether to
go or stop on the decision i just be
more like we have different models of
the world
so null hypothesis significance testing
is a statistical mathematical procedure
that kind of is supposed to do the
adjudication process but it's just such
a crude model of things and bayesian
hypothesis testing is also a crude model
and posterior predictive checking is
great but it's not about adjudicating
between two models it's it's it's
something different right um so i think
that we have to
we have a tendency often to identify
the statistical method
with the goal
and i think that's wrong and i've said
this for a while but what i only
recently felt
realized was that
we have to think of these goals in the
in the context of what we do which is as
i said
when you're doing data science or
statistics i think you're acting like a
little baby scientist
like you're you're trying things out
you're trying to understand things and i
think we we need to fit our theories
around that
um but between now and then i just want
you to try to use the
use the methods you have available to
you but be aware that you are doing this
sort of exploration
so i hope this will be helpful to you in
in the coming year
thank you very much
excellent as always
thank you for the opportunity to talk
with these people of course we love this
all right folks we are believe it or not
back on schedule